cette centrale photovoltaïque de la
chapelle-saint-ursin est en pleine
construction
elle sera la plus puissante du cher avec
une puissance de près de 22 mégawatts
les postes de transformation viennent
juste d'être livrés sur cette centrale
la kiffer 21,5 mégawatts on a trois
postes de transformation et un poste de
livraison pour ramener sur le réseau et
sur le raccordement du sur le poste
source qui est à 300 mètres 52 mille
panneaux de dernière génération qui vont
donner plus de rendement au projet ce
sont des panneaux dernière génération
des panneaux de double face c'est à dire
qu'ils sont capables de capter l'énergie
solaire est de produire l'énergie qui
compte en direct soit face avant et qui
produisent aussi des l'énergie par la
face arrière donc comme on voit là sont
des panneaux qui ont qui captent la
lumière qui va revenir remontée du sol
c'était rien n'avait plus d'utilité
depuis l'abandon du projet de port sec
suite à l'explosion de l'usiné azf à
toulouse en 2001 sont devenues
maintenant une aubaine on s'est dit le
meilleur usage qu'on peut faire de cet
espace inutilisable aussi bien au plan
agricole qu'industriel centrales
photovoltaïques
on a donc travaillé à ce projet est
aujourd'hui whaou une manne très
importante pour l'agglomération de
bourges et en même temps un espace
naturel ou des moutons viendront paître
tranquillement